ihr habt eure fragen geschickt und ich
beantworte sie jetzt
mister spock start fragt was ist deine
lieblings science fiction film serie ja
die steckt schon in deinem namen genau
star trek und zwar eigentlich habe ich
alles gesehen die ur serie next
generation also alles was es da gab habe
ich verschlungen
ja ich finde das ist wirklich die beste
science-fiction-serie auch wenn man sich
überlegt die ersten folgen
die haben ja wirklich es steve jobs dazu
angeregt seine geräte also das ipad das
iphone so zu design wie sie jetzt
geworden sind also man kann sagen star
trek ist eine wirklich weltbewegende
serie gewesen sie hat sogar die zukunft
beeinflusst und dazu geführt dass wir
heute solche geräte hier in der hand
halten die so ein bisschen wie der
communicator in star trek funktionieren
benjamin grenzfrage was fasziniert dich
so an der astronomie
also ich finde es spannend dass wir dann
noch so unglaublich wenig darüber wissen
wobei ich interessiere mich eigentlich
für beides astronomie und teilchenphysik
weil in der teilchenphysik dringen wir
auch immer tiefer in immer kleinere
einheiten einsehen finden immer neue
teilte mit explosion das gesetz
nachgewiesen worden ist
und im gros in der galaxie entdecken wir
auch ständig neue phänomene der dunkle
materie sind noch hinterher
und so weiter und so fort unser gibt's
noch so wahnsinnig viel zu entdecken in
beiden in dem ganz großen und in dem
ganz kleinen und beides finde ich
unglaublich spannend weil wir da an den
grenzen sind an den grenzen dessen was
wir wissen und deshalb immer wieder
neues erfahren gm möchte wissen wenn du
die möglichkeit hast zum mond zu fliegen
würdest du sie annehmen und das wollen
einige von mir wissen hat mit drei likes
auf jeden fall also ich finde das so
spannend das exotische land auf der welt
ist ja schon super interessant wobei ist
jetzt nicht welches es gibt da waren
sich viele tolle spannende interessante
länder auf der welt aber auf einem
anderen gestürmt zu sein
das fände ich glaube ich dass das den
absoluten wahnsinn auch wenn es
natürlich super anstrengend auch
gefährlich natürlich ist aber das würde
mich so reizen
das wird nicht unbedingt machen und das
fantastische ist man sieht mal die welt
aus einem anderen blickwinkel und das
finde ich glaube ich würde ich fast
jeden menschen mal empfehlen weil dann
wird man glaube ich ganz schnell
begreifen dass all der streit und die
kriege und auseinandersetzungen die wir
auf der erde haben eigentlich totaler
quatsch sind weil wir leben auf einem
planeten sind eine einheit wir sind
alles menschen und auch mit allem was
wir haben das es waren sich wertvoll und
wir sollten alles dazu tun um das zu
schützen alexander sheridan
wie kann man jemanden etwas portale
portieren noch geht es nicht aber in der
teilchenphysik ist etwas ähnliches
passiert und zwar das funktioniert mit
verschränkten teilchen das heißt es gibt
in der teilchenphysik die das phänomen
dass zwei teilchen miteinander verbunden
sind und zwar so dass wenn man dem einen
teilchen etwas mit dem etwas macht
passiert exakt das gleiche mit dem
anderen teilchen auf diese weise konnte
jetzt schon in einem experiment die
projektion einer katze mit lichtteilchen
eben parallel mitteilte lieber an einem
anderen ort waren genauso erzeugt werden
eins zu eins kopie und das ist eine art
b das heißt man manipuliert über die
ferne und das würde natürlich auch atome
bezogen bedeutet und auf viele zb ein
mensch dass man wenn man dort etwas
erzeugt dann wird es auf der anderen
seite genauso auch erzeugt also das wäre
eine methode zu bild ja mal gucken ob es
irgendwann gelingt es ist natürlich
wahnsinnig komplex summaries auch ein
video zu macht ist in dem video
beschreibung verlinkt sut rtr hat folge
frage kennst du kleine wissenschafts
kanäle bzw kannst du welche empfehlen ja
auf jeden fall und zwar die 4 100
sekunden physik break alles musik und
text as tisch das sind die kleinen
wissenschafts kanäle wobei so klein sind
sie ja gar nicht mehr
die ich unbedingt empfehlen kann und
wenn euch dieses video gefallen hat dann
kann ich euch nur das
letzte video auch empfehlen fragte geht
das gibt hier und wenn ihr fragen habt
stellt sie hier unter dem video ich bin
gespannt und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran